[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys and welcome back to the lehigh
pen show powered by
icon plus since it's powered by openplus
i have a news announcement for you
so more than 60 of ics tokens are locked
up by investors
which means that more people are
investing long term in icon
and actually earning up to 12 interest
per year
passive income so this is also powered
by
and sponsored by block five so i want to
give a quick shout out to them and say
thank you
um because i actually use them to earn
up to 8.6 interest on my uscc usdc is a
stable coin
so you can earn so much interest when
you're in crypto so
i'm going to leave the link in the
description in the bio wherever you want
to get it and you can earn i think
actually at the moment it's around 250
if you deposit with them and before we
start the show a last final shout out to
coinflip so coinflip are doing some
incredible work across the states
they're pushing bitcoin mass adoption
they have um a bunch of atms i think
it's nearly over 800 atms in 45
different states so huge shout out to
them they're doing some amazing work
so joining me today is somebody a little
different i'm really excited to chat to
him it's going to be super unfiltered
um i actually have no specific questions
lined up it's just gonna be
um we're just gonna go for it okay so um
so he is a boxer entrepreneur
competitive chess player
and he focuses on self-improvement it is
of course
ed latimore how are you doing i'm doing
fantastic you know i heard you going
through all the sponsors and i said you
know what
i'm a fish out of water because i don't
know
anything about krypto and i should and
i'm sure
that's like that's like admitting you
don't believe in god in the church like
me saying that
right yeah sure but uh
but but eventually uh i'm sure i will
learn about it because it seems like the
kind of thing
where if you don't learn about it you're
at a marked
disadvantage moving forward in the
future
100 i actually wasn't even gonna bring
crypto up but since we're here
i wasn't gonna do it but but since we're
here you are somebody who's all about
you know you're an entrepreneur you're
all about sort of like doing a best
pushing forward and pushing through the
pain
you know forgetting the emotion just
keep going i feel like
and also you're all about taking
personal responsibility i feel like
that's totally in line
with crypto and particularly with
bitcoin like do you have any interest
whatsoever
well you you know so all of that yes
all of that is perfectly in line with
the philosophy and i've actually read uh
what is that that book the bitcoin
standard i thought it was a great great
book um
if for any other reason it made me
understand exactly
what money is and how money works i said
okay that's a really cool idea
uh as far as my personal interest
and it goes right now it seems like a
thing
to invest in like a commodity um what i
what i was interested in
initially was like okay is this going to
be a thing that eventually
in my lifetime replaces fiat currency
and if it does then what are the
implications
of that for a regular person because you
have to remember uh i
i think i'm very i think i'm blessed in
the perspective that i get
grown because i grew up uh
extraordinarily poor as poor as you can
really be in america and not be homeless
i was in public housing
i believe you guys call those
commonwealth estates over in the uk
i grew up in the car's car council
stages
yeah i grew up in in that environment
and then
you know i had a brief step with the
middle class and i think
i think there's no real definitely not
middle class anymore i don't know if i'm
i'm officially like upper class but
definitely not there
but what that what that does is having
that going through that path of life is
you
have perspective and my perspective
is okay like how does the normal person
make use of
this and if i can't if i can't get to
how a regular person
who wakes up at like you know 10 at
night
and wants to go get some 40s down the
block like if i can't figure out how
they're gonna use it
uh to do so then then i'm not there you
know
which which like one of the things to
change my mind is a whole only fans
thing for example
my first thought was like okay guys that
want to go to the strip club
how they gonna drop you know make it
rain with bitcoin
and then they're gonna make it rain with
bitcoin
all of a sudden you have this this
influx of
it's the best way to put this digital
yes digital voyeurism and there's a lot
of
there are a lot of different ways to pay
pay for your pleasure now
and and all those can be those
transactions can be conducted in a
digital manner
so i think as the world moves more
digital uh it it starts making more
sense to me how the common person gets
involved with it and i think the
ultimate
dream uh if i'm not mistaken
of many people who are in the space uh
what we realize which is that it
replaces
uh fiat non-bad
currency uh but but right now my mind
can't get there and then you know what
does that have to do with my interest in
it uh
right now because i'm so focused on
uh generating a certain amount of income
my mind just does not
let me go invest in some things now that
is definitely changing
uh probably in 2021 but uh
that i'm just explaining my past and why
i've not converted
uh to the church of bitcoin
yeah okay so you so much gone on there
so firstly i think that's really
interesting you make such an interesting
point about you know sex work is now
online
i'm actually not a huge fan of that
industry
but um as a woman i would say i think
it's an incredible option because it's
safer
and you know people can pay in bitcoin
and bitcoin at the moment is on the
absolute run so you know speaking of
coming from such a poor background if
somebody gave you like 50
let's just say um i don't know whether
like a few months ago you would have
absolutely you know made a lot of money
on it by now and you'll continue to
um but i wanted to talk about you mainly
don't talk too much about bitcoin but i
think that's super cool
no but it's cool it's cool it's cool
that you have an interest in it but
i want to talk about you because you are
a lot of different things you're a boxer
author competitive chess player so it's
insanely
diverse so how would you define yourself
uh i am someone who
[Music]
who i i heard this phrase i don't know
if you're familiar with a hotep jesus
but i heard that phrase he he used it on
donovan's sharp show
he's i'm a guy who realized that his
life didn't match his ambition
and so one day i woke up and i said okay
how do i
how do i start making how i see myself
become reflected in reality so other
people see me that same way
and i said okay let me let me go and do
the things that challenge me and push me
that other people
won't do can't do and see how far i can
go
you know i my motto like i always tell
people
when they go are you afraid about afraid
of getting hurt in the ring or dawn or
whatever and i'm gonna die anyway right
let me get some stories
out of this life at least you know at
least when i'm old someone's not like oh
goodness here comes grandpa getting like
not
like okay man here comes this guy he's
got something cool to talk about
and and that mentality you know perhaps
is not the
physically safest but it has led to a
very interesting
life because i didn't start boxing when
i was younger like i made a conscious
decision as an adult to go i'm going to
go
do this and not only am i gonna go do it
uh
at a high enough level you know if i can
get there but i wanna i'm gonna do it
the right way which is start as an
amateur no one's paying you no one cares
most of your fights you know a lot of
them get cancer you waste all evening
and stuff like that
but but it pushes you and you developed
uh you develop a
a certain kind of grit that you can't
get anywhere else
and it also and i talk about this a lot
one of the best things boxing did for me
is it
shifted my mindset from
fix to growth i had a fixed mindset
about about a lot of things
academically and and i said wait a
second
if i can learn how to fight man because
i was not very
good when i started and and i did not
think
i thought i was going to become good i'm
sure a lot of people around me didn't
think
much would develop of me but i
kept learning the diligent approach
whatever
and when i when i seen what that did for
my amateur career and in my professional
career i said okay
you know if i did it there can i do the
same thing for my mind
can i can i make myself uh
intelligent can i approach problems that
i had probably because i had a
big issue with math i wrote about it on
my site uh a few different articles
and i said no we're gonna we're gonna do
this like boxing because it can't be
worse than boxing because this is a real
like negative feedback mechanism when
you make a mistake worst thing that
happens i get the wrong
answer in a math problem right so
i took that approach and and it helped
me become
who i am today and get through those
things to get my physics degree to go on
and now learn chess and writing the
whole idea
to sum me up is is i believe that
if i have if i'm given enough time i can
learn anything
and i'm going to choose things that are
going to force me to develop
and that's really what my life is about
i try to continue to develop myself
and continue to improve and i know i'll
never max out i'm gonna die before them
but that's no reason to not try right
yeah i think there's so much going on
here so i want to kind of go back
to you know because you said you did
grow up in a council estate
it was very very poor um you know you
were very poor school was very difficult
and
there wasn't a lot going on essentially
um i think i read on your site you said
you that you had a lot of anger issues
so you've clearly gone from i mean at
the beginning you sort of said my upper
class now you know so you've gone from
you've done like three classes you know
if that's even possible so
my question to you then is you know what
is going on right now because
if we look at today's world we have
there's a lot of issues in terms of
culture wars class wars um you know
people
sort of the idea of personal
responsibility is sort of frowned upon
um you know people sort of are unable to
you know do anything great for
themselves because they have a million
reasons why they can't
so coming from such a background that
you came from
why do you think you were able to but
other people
aren't able to and also actually ask the
next bit after go for it and also then i
will ask it now
i i remember i was i was reading and you
said you know your father wasn't always
super present so even you had that
against you as a young
man so how how does that go
why why were you able to and other
people can't
um uh aside from luck right because
that's a useless
i don't believe in life um
you know i i
i remember that
i never wanted to feel
weak and i figured out
very early that there are a few ways to
feel weak and i
i tried to avoid all of one
is when when people had control over how
you felt they can make you feel a
certain way
they can make you angry they can make
you cry
whatever right they can make you divert
your uh
path i remember one time i was afraid of
this bullying on my bus so i started
walking to school
now remember i'm i'm like i mean like
like probably i remember where i lived
so i was probably like seven
and i'm walking like over two two miles
to school whatever
and that's uh that's hard
that's a thing that you don't ever want
like you don't want to experience that
type of weakness so
so you learn you start you start
experimenting with ways to not
experience
that and and one of the biggest ways is
to to always be in control yourself
when you're always in control yourself
what happens is you you start having a
certain expectation
heaped upon you and either you rise to
meet that
or you you get punished and you lose you
know freedoms abilities
um access to things that can
they can make your time pass better
okay so here it all starts with the
emotional control and not being
responsive to my environment
creating my own kind of inner peace in
my own world because that mean i had to
there was there was nothing
around me that suggested uh
safety or security or peace i had to
create those environments
up here and in doing so i went all right
why can't i can do this
what else helps me do that okay doing
the opposite of everyone around me and
it just not just so happens i mean i had
to do it because i didn't want to be
part of that environment
because i was trying to create a space
different than what was around me
that meant showing up on time for
example
like i actually i mean i'm still to this
day a stickler about time
like really cats down people are late or
my
my girlfriend jokes that like we get to
the airport two hours early
all the time it's not really jumping i
guess we do because i'm i'm so
terrified of like being late but
[Laughter]
you get it right so so i try to be in
control of my time
uh i try to
if i see a difficulty i don't ever want
that difficulty to sneak up on me
because one of the things you just
learned that if you face it
head on you might not get an advantage
but you
aren't at a disadvantage at least not as
big
at least not a bigger one than if you
try to escape it
and you have to deal with it eventually
so how i
developed this mindset again i have to
face
this problem before this problem decides
to face
me because if it fazes me uh and i'm not
ready
we got a big problem or i like to say
you know you can pay now
or you can pay later if you paid now you
might get a discount if you pay later
you're
definitely going to have to kick it with
interest so you pick
which one is up you know which one you
want to do so
having that mentality right so now i got
control of my time
now and then i'm trying to create my
environment
and in doing so i have to face any
problem that comes up
and the ability to do that to recognize
what a problem is
is is i i never got a chance to deceive
myself
i never got a chance to believe that
someone was my friend
if they weren't because that was a
costly mistake
i never got a chance to believe that
something would turn out okay just
because i hoped it did i always went and
made
sure uh things will work the way i
wanted them to
i never got comfortable letting things
be out of my control
and so if if i'm able to
do those four things and this is really
the first time i've ever kind of broken
that down maybe i'll like
turn it into an article or something but
if i'm able to do those four things
if i'm able to control my emotions and
then control my environment
face problems as they're coming at me
and i can face them
because i do not let myself become
deceived by reality
and this and remember this isn't like me
as a kid going this is my master plan
for ruling the world now this is just so
i can cope with the day-to-day
like like either at school or at home
you get those you know i got those four
things done and so
so i don't i don't understand
how one is able to
live not in control not wanting to be in
control looking
for anything to blame looking for things
to be outraged about
like all of those things go against
everything that has helped me survive
and continues to help me thrive you know
i think that's fascinating um you know
you say these are the things that helped
you
survive um i just for me you know i i
totally agree with you anyway which is
obviously you know one of the main
reasons why
you know i saw you online and i was like
oh wow i really agree with everything
this guy is saying
i think it's such a shame um that
people are unable to adopt these kind of
mentalities or don't agree with these
mentalities
um because you know i know you agree
anyway but no one's coming to save you
right so i think it's such a shame that
we can't sort of agree that no one's
coming to save us because
even the government you know even if
they let's say they really did have our
best intentions at heart
they literally just can't there's too
many people you know what i mean
and even if they did come and save you
they it would
the only way that money really could
stretch is to bring everybody down to
the lowest common denominator which is
communism but communism aside
you know oh man you're spitting right
now
you're saying something okay
one of the things i was just talking
about this with my buddy uh yesterday
and it always i i came to this
conclusion maybe last year
that there aren't really two political
parties wow i know you guys are in the
uk you
are in europe you have a bit of a
different system no we're the same
two parties right but there there's uh
there's not really two political parties
it's not really conservative liberal
nothing what it is
is it's people who believe
that something is going to save or
protect them
whether that be the government whether
that be a god
whatever okay and it's people who
understand that no one is coming to save
them and they've got to figure this
thing out on their own
and if you look at it that way
it's not entirely accurate but it's
useful enough and precise enough to
where you can make
accurate predictions and useful
predictions
for example i should not be able to but
we can
i should not be able to look at your
stance on the coronavirus and tell
where you lean politically but i can and
the reason
for that is there tends to be a strong
enough overlap remember the model is not
perfect but it's useful enough to where
we can make useful
uh or we can make some predictions that
allow us
to determine the best kind of course of
action to go
i can look at how you feel about one
thing and guess how you feel about a
bunch of other things because
of that model if you think the
government is coming to save you
you probably support all kinds of things
where i just go
ah i can't really get behind it i mean
like good for you
but i can kind of see where this is
going to go
and you know a great example of this is
one of the arguments that we have
here in the united states is the 15
minimum wage okay and
and and on one side it's like oh great
everyone has more money me on the other
hand because i could never i never let
myself get deceived by reality so one of
the things that i
studied it was economics just being
curious and i'm like okay
so if we if we do this then what about
all the people
who make 14 an hour who were skilled
and also what happens when that's the
new minimum wage and everyone just
raises the prices and now we've just got
inflation
and yeah it's like you want to start a
business
and you can't afford to pay someone 15
an hour then it's just like that
completely ostracizes the people that
they're trying to help you know
like people like yourself who came from
those kind of backgrounds well sorry
you're just not worth fifteen dollars
right it's hilarious and and you know to
that
because then what happens a lot of times
when you when you try to think like this
you
often come up with ideas that are
counter-intuitive and perhaps not
entirely popular
and one day i was just sitting around
thinking about it and maybe i was trying
to troll maybe i wasn't
but i was thinking and i said you know
really the best thing to do in this
like if you're really worried about
people being paid a great wage
the best thing to do would be to get rid
of the minimum wage entirely and let
and let and let competition sorted out
and people were like
what i just kept thinking about it maybe
and i don't know if that is the most
correct answer i'm just
riffing here to make an example of the
the two different thought processes
but uh some people will go that's great
because i have the skill to take care of
myself and i'll figure it out
and on the other side people go that's
horrible
we need regulations and plays we need
someone
to take care of and protect us now you
can't go you know completely extreme or
one extreme you get anarchism
anarchy and the other extreme you get
communism but like
you know people who tend to lean a
little
closer to anarchy probably tend to think
more like me and people who
tend to lean a little more towards
communism but they'll never say that
uh tend to think not like me
yeah i think but also i think what we
tend to forget when we talk about
minimum wage is that minimum wage was
never supposed to be living wage
you know it was never supposed to be
something which um you know will allow
you to
rent and pay your bills and
a little cushion you know so that you
can afford potentially to
um buy a really cheap suit after you've
been working at this place for so long
and then you can afford to um you know
put that nice suit on
to go to another interview and work your
way up like it was just supposed to be
like a little
like it was never supposed to be
something which could pay your bills
um and actually you make a really good
point about the model of personal
responsibility so this is hilarious i
don't know
you may have heard this i'm not sure but
i think it was a uk
article they basically made um a
headline
the headline was something like if
you're a gym bro if like you're one of
those guys that
you know gym and all this stuff um
you're more likely to be a radical
right-wing
person because you take personal
responsibility for your health and the
way you look physically
you know you don't have to stop for
movement which basically says it's okay
to be fat
it's okay to be unhealthy um you know
they've taken personal responsibility so
that makes them more likely to be
right-wing
it's the same thing here you know the
joke is i can tell
i can tell which side of the line you're
on by the strength of your headshake
i don't know if one would say
fortunately or unfortunately but there
is
a lot more truth in that than i think
either sod wants there
to be but at the end of the day you know
i i think people people think that uh
i'm
i like lead and right or whatever i have
no idea what i lean because i don't pay
attention to politics
i know that i'm for personal
responsibility
and it seems like uh that is
a model or a um our policy
of of one side of one take and that is
you know coincidence at best
uh you know at worst you know probably
someone
actively trying to uh keep one group of
people or many groups of people
dependent on the government and those
who don't
think that way or are radicals black
sheeps uncle toms whatever you want to
call it
yeah i think it's a shame because i
because i think i actually think you
know this kind of mentality is the only
way to succeed if you continue
um to sort of take a victim mindset if
you continue to sort of say i can't and
i i'm
i'm you know the world is against me and
i need to vote this way i need to listen
i need to make democrats so that they
can save me and all this stuff
you'll never get out of it it's sort of
like a continuation
um i just feel like this kind of
mentality perpetuates it um
but i want to talk a little bit actually
um about masculinity in today's
world um because you you mentioned that
you know your father wasn't really
present and that was a lot that was you
had a lot of abuse growing up and all
these all these different things so
what are your thoughts on masculinity
today
um from my perspective i see there's a
huge
um i feel like there's a huge
feminization of
men um you know that was the recent um
picture of harry styles and a dress and
all these things and i will say each
other
each to their own whatever you want to
do but i just wanted to get your opinion
on it um
what what is going on yeah you know it's
cool you know it's cool
because like uh i can tell if you're
bringing this up
you know you're probably you you're
probably
on my side or you're setting a trap uh
don't think you said the trap so
it's all things are good um no but in
all seriousness
i i think
okay so sexual dimorphism
is is a thing like
you don't look like me and i don't look
like you
and that is a that's just a feature of
the species right you know we're not
gonna dive into the benefits pros cons
of it that's just
uh what we are and each of us
because of that because of the
dimorphism we come with
certain strengths and certain weaknesses
each of us
it's it's a great error
to group
all the the the
okay so so what happens with the toxic
masculinity movement
oh is that they throw the baby out with
the bath water
they take traits that are masculine and
they're just
bad okay not not the same thing can be
happening but it happens
you know like
yeah stuff like that yeah but but but
like 12
no no no the same thing happens with
women you know but to a lesser extent
almost to a non-existent extent because
like now you know
it's been it's effectively a crime
really to criticize uh
women publicly but what what happened
you know
what happens with a lot of the masculine
traits is
you know they're they're immoral they're
neither good nor bad it's just
you know who who wields them you know is
your is your villain
uh the only difference between a villain
and a good villain and a good hero
is is one well his perspective or the
perspective of the people against
and and how he decides to use it you
know uh the strength is
strength whether it's used to build or
destroy uh
uplift or control uh dominate
or dedicate you know it's all
strengthened it is a masculine virtue
a dedication intensity all of these
things
here's the problem okay now that we've
kind of
loosely defined what what masculinity is
this kind of active force in the world
that's amoral but makes things happen
okay uh here's the problem
when when it starts when you're younger
okay it starts with boys being being a i
think it was like
five i did a presentation on this uh two
years ago or a year ago i think and i
think it was about
five times more likely to be diagnosed
with adhd
now now if it was then now why is that
it's not like it's not that boys
are are you know have problems focusing
it's that
we we have a world a structure for young
for young boys where they're told sit
still in the classroom
for freaking almost eight hours a day
and there's something wrong with you if
you can't
and that's problematic we have
deregulated uh a deregulated unregulated
sexual market we actually have a little
little worse than that if you can like
an unregulated market is a black market
right in a black market
uh if you cross somebody they can come
and cross you back
and that's what a black market is pretty
much
operating outside the law and the
criminals you know keep things in check
we call this prison justice right as
street justice
well it's a bit worse than that because
if if if a woman
accuses you of something false for
example there's no recourse if she's
caught really
at least not nearly as serious of a want
to deter it
um there is no recourse you know if you
decide you don't want the kid but she
does you still have to pay
right uh dave chappelle made a great
great joke about that he goes you know
your body your choice
my wallet mantra you keep but i decide i
want to pay for them right
and then that's like where that is a
reasonable reaction a regional status
but that's not there uh
why do i bring that up not just to go
you know [ __ ] on the movement
but to highlight that we've we've now
incentivized
and forget disincentivizing with shame
right there because as we used to have
we used to disincentivize single moms
where there was no male in our household
and raised we used to just
disincentivize
um the rampant sexuality we used to
disincentivize that
no more shame shame died and then maybe
when i was in high school
now we've incentivized it we've
incentivized it because there's a
government state that will make sure
you're okay
like no matter what you won't be okay
because we're gonna give you some money
if you have this kid and not only that
we're gonna
we're gonna find that we're gonna
legally attack the
the father the kid you know now he
should be responsible but
my point here is that the word though
the weight of
responsibility is not equal it's gone
and you know so so how does this all
relate to to god's you know kind of the
wall masculinity whatever
is not only are we told it's bad
from the from our development you know
standpoint
but we're also not getting good examples
of it at home because
many more kids are being raised without
fathers in their life
than they are right so that's happening
the school is insulting you on your on
you being a boy
uh by virtue of the girl's position very
often she's more likely
to be believed i mean that there are so
many there
are many many stories of that all she
had all it takes is one
accusation as opposed to due process
before someone's life
for for a god's life is ripped to
absolute shreds
and that is problematic it's highly
problematic
so you've got these these things in
place and yet
i i am a firm believer uh that there's
there's an attack
on on what it takes to be a man and
that's just one aspect of another aspect
is the world is very easy now
and one of the things that kind of
shaped what made you a man was
overcoming hardship there are no
hardships to overcome and
we we are basically wally the only the
only difference between here
uh between this between 2020
and wally is in wally they figured out
space so they're in space they get
technology but it's the same thing you
know you you can sit in your house i
remember even 10 years ago when i was 25
you know um if i'm only if i only made
800 a month man i had a rough life 800
a month now that's a netflix
subscription that's some cheap food it
can be
brought to you and walked to you know
cheap liquor um
an only fan subscription or all the porn
in the world
so in case i don't you know which
completely demotivates
you know we're not even gonna get
started on the poor thing but that's
another force that just completely
because they trap you they're like drug
addicts it's like okay here's this
here's here's some breasts come on in
check it out
you don't have to put in the work you
don't have to put in the work you don't
have to do anything
it's it's all just it's all just there
for you yeah that's insane
that's insane to think that actually 800
would get you so much
because you know we think about like
inflation though but we think about
inflation and like eight hundred dollars
was obviously worth more ten years ago
but maybe a thousand works no no but i'm
with you
no but i'm with you because we didn't
you didn't have all of this ten years
ago so
um yeah i'm talking with you
it's crazy because me humans in general
i think
need a thing to push against but within
that subspecies
men more men need things to push against
they need things to challenge them they
need to be able
when they're younger they're not being
told that wanting to
to run around and play sports and have a
lot of energy is a bad thing they need
role models all these things are gone
and
yeah i think ease is in place of it and
so
it's gonna become harder and harder
for for guys to develop into men a good
friend of mine
told me he's got a bunch of kids he said
he's more worried
about his daughters being able to find a
decent guy
to be with and his son being able to
find
a woman because there because nothing
has
in terms of the environment that is that
is ideal for
for producing a woman so there are some
things that are like
not good like you know the the financial
incentive of only fans and the porno
sites
uh that's certainly no good but there's
not anything that actively
impedes their development just
distractions along the path
that with a good home life are
largely avoidable like a good family
not so much for god's
god god needs to be needs to get his ass
kicked for example now we got
anti-bullying i'm not saying we need
bullies in schools but i'm saying you
know
guys still a conflict differently we can
fight and then be
friends and but you gotta fight first
but there are many more examples for
strong women
in society they're all for men i gave a
speech at a program
and and the woman came to me she said
you know the the
if you can would love for you to talk to
somebody god specifically
because the girls get tons of attention
this is a woman i think she was
in our late 50s early 60s uh so
so from another era and notice
says that the gods are not getting the
attention and the
the effort energy and and i know i i
i 100 feel it man because i i didn't
have any of that i think that's why
uh i was interested in football and then
once football was gone in high school i
kind of floated around wayward and
then i didn't book but but something
said you got to find a thing
to put some sweat equity in and
i found boxing and which in which these
are hard environments that shape you
and force you to be disciplined and
accountable and you have the channel
your energy and channel your aggression
all the things that society
does not have an outlet for you to do
for god to do you can do it in boxing
and it's great like we have
so many different ways and outlets
scholarships
for and everything um many different
ways that are forming to
doesn't have to be success now it's a
zero-sum game so
the more one side gets a thing the less
the other side gets and when we did that
and we've done this for a long time we
as humans have to come up with a better
way
because it used to be the other way
right
uh where it was where god's gotta there
there was much more
in for society out there for god's but
not so much for for women if they wanted
to venture out but
you know that gets into to another
argument but the the tldr to to kind of
put a cap on this this uh this part of
the conversation
is that is it it is it is very hard for
a boy to develop into a man today and
it's only going to get harder the easier
society gets
and and part of becoming easy almost by
definition and i mean this is
easy isn't not facing resistance for
anyone who wants to make a joke
but part of becoming uh a man is the
is that life is gonna come easier and
a feminized or women seek a path kind of
less resistance certainly physically and
into a lesser extent emotionally
and guys don't get that option but they
but they but it doesn't come from
nowhere you got to develop it
society's making it hard to develop yeah
that was a lot there
um i want to okay no it's good it's good
it's good um
so two things i want to mention the
first just back to what you initially
said
um i'm absolutely with you i think
there's a lot of i think the government
has disincentivized
um not just men and but just people in
general um
to sort of like doing the the thing
which creates the better outcome right
so if it's sort of like um if it's like
you know
a family unit kids and all this stuff
like you said
they'll pay for you they'll pick they'll
reward you with money
when you have let's say children outside
of a marriage and this and that and
you don't want to be responsible for it
so that like you said they will pay you
and support you
so it disincentivizes you from wanting
to do what could
create a better outcome long term but it
is um actually international
men's wednesday yeah so congrats happy
international wednesday
okay yeah so i i
was at conception and here i am here you
are i don't no no no no listen i'm
the fact that you didn't know basically
just proves everything you said right
because you would know if it was
international women's day
oh yeah yeah exactly
it's a great point i i and and if i
wanted to i'd have to
block the hashtag but i know at that
point but i wouldn't block it i mean
i've got i've got nothing against
my word at all no of course not but what
i want to what i want to say actually
is because you spoke a lot about boxing
and how you know it's sort of necessary
needs that sort of
physical um that physical challenge in
order to become a man
he needs all these challenges you know
spoke about adhd and all this stuff
um but from a female perspective i think
of course it's different you were saying
you know men need that to become a woman
sorry to become a man women don't need
that to become a woman
but what i would say in terms of
building strong people regardless of
gender
um from just my experience i think the
best thing that
men like yourself who are into
self-improvement
and you know challenging yourself
physically can offer women is
encouraging them to
do physical challenge right so i saw um
i saw a video earlier today of a dad
helping his his little girl in the gym
and i was like that is perfect i was
like that this is it this is what women
need this is how men can benefit women
this is how they add value to women
because they're you know we all we both
add value to each other
um whether it's you know whether it's
you know we help men when it comes to
sort of bringing out their more
emotional side or nurturing or whatever
it is love and all this stuff and care
which is totally f we're happy to i'm
happy to do that that's you know what it
is
and i think from my experience you know
my brother for example
was a huge role model for me and he's
the one that got me in the gym
and he's the one that will turn around
to me and say oh my god leia of course
you can do that you can do anything and
then i'm like
oh yeah of course they can do anything
you know and that that kind of
rational that kind of like unemotional
hard opinion sort of it comes mainly
from men that sort of unemotional like
yeah you could do it like you know and i
think women need that and i think that's
that kind of strength that men have is
what adds a lot of value to women and i
kind of wanted to highlight that on
international women's day because
that's sort of wednesday sorry because
that's my that's
that's the thing that i find just to be
the most amazing thing about men in
general
for me they add so much value in terms
of making me feel powerful
and like i can i appreciate that and
what you said
is so key and i wish everyone understood
it
we need each other we we were not
one of the things about a sexual
dimorphism
when we're so different is that to be
whole we need one another one of the
things
uh i i say i i made a point is that you
know when
when two things are equal by definition
you don't need one of them but when
they're
complementary you do and we
complement one another so well we you
you're strong we're weak and we're weak
where you're strong
and together a society is built
my fear my worry and this
is where the world is going uh is that
the the strengths are
muted and the weaknesses
don't necessarily rise because you're
not designed to rise like like no matter
how much
you put in the gym uh you ain't never
gonna be as big
as me like ain't never gonna happen and
likewise
uh i i don't and i'm pretty pretty damn
good with people i would never want to
talk as much
as a typical woman and make that
connection i'm never going to
feel good that way that lately
and that's important people need to be
comforted people need to become
we need strength to protect said
comforting ability
but when you mute the differences
you take away the most beautiful part of
each of us
and you make us when we're more weaker
and that's what i think
happens because because um
gaps don't don't stay empty for long
if you if the less masculine you make
men the the more you punish their
masculinity
the more you're forcing a woman to
become masculine
and neither people are comfortable in
the road or both
weaker you're not you don't get the
focus on being you
and i don't get to focus on being me and
so now we're just kind of a mess
floating around neither one of us is
really good i forget jack of all trades
master
kind of bad at everything now and
that is that is the biggest kind of
danger i think
so so i really appreciate that that
notice
of the role of encouraging
and supporting kind of no nonsense
objective
you can do this attitude as opposed to
because i mean because it was you and
you recognized like
like a girlfriend would be like oh you
know like like
you may not get as much practical advice
on how to do it but you'll get a
cheerleader
yeah exactly you need somebody that's
like
you got this no matter what you're
amazing you're wonderful
you go girl like you need that but you
also need someone to be like look here
we got this this and this and you can't
you can't face that right now
but if we go here and maybe get in the
gym like six months you can be eye to
face this one and when you get that one
you'll be ready for that one like
they're they're true so much they're
great i provide them
one isn't better than the other they
they're just they but they
when you have both you become
unstoppable i mean you have neither
which is kind of where we're trending
you can do nothing yeah absolutely um
totally with you you need both you're
right you need that you go girl you got
this you're beautiful
you you know you got this and then you
need the okay stop crying
this isn't going to help you know you
need that you do
but i think i think it's interesting
though particularly like the
the whole feminism movement and
everything because
it's sort of what the most weird the
most confusing part to me
is that it sort of encourages women
to um empower themselves obviously it's
feminism but
by sort of removing their feminine
traits
which is so odd to me right so it's like
less so i'm not saying that
i'm not saying like feminism is i'm not
saying like being a woman is defined by
how long your hair is and like
what you wear and all this stuff of
course it goes much deeper than that but
you'll have to find that people who are
sort of
promoting feminism are sort of like um
rejecting traditional feminine values
which is really odd to me it's sort of
like a contradiction
you know yeah it's it's really
interesting it's it's like you know
to be better black people we're gonna
stop being black i mean like that would
be
is that that sounds weird and silly
but i i don't think ever every the
history is just a series of over
corrections
um and when you look at it that way
then every everything makes sense
because because look
as much as some people want to like rag
on the feminist movement
you have to understand it it sprung up
because
well at one point you know women were
getting getting left high and dry
by guys but when the law only you know
you didn't you
should i got the right to vote for boy
in the united states before you got the
right to vote you know
blacks before and we and we didn't think
we were treated like nothing
so at some point uh you just got to look
at like how did all of this start and
then you go okay
and this you know then you go all right
well we see how this happened and see
how this happened
we can't really fix the pass let's just
kind of start all over and wipe the
slate clean
i don't i don't know if that'll ever
happen that's that's like forgiveness on
a
on a massive scale that humanity
desperately needs but we'll
and i'm incapable of likely never get
there and i'm a huge proponent
of forgiveness so my mind immediately
went well you know
you're never gonna really be able to
balance this out you just gotta wipe
this clean and
and move forward but we'll see you know
uh
people give me hope not so much recently
but
but but in general man adaptability is
the name of our species or
our ours as a trait of our species so
hopefully i think forgiveness yeah i
think forgiveness is huge i think that's
such a big point that you mentioned and
i think that's probably actually one of
like the biggest issues in society
everybody's so
angry at everyone right like everyone is
a minority
in some place in the world um you know
whether it's your
i don't know whether it's like you're
black you're white you're jewish you're
fat you're short
your ginger you're whatever the hell you
are you know
you're asian you know somebody's not
gonna like you um
i just think everyone's so angry like
constantly
so important they're they're angry and
even worse
they're angry about things they can't do
anything about and when i say
they can't do anything about it i i
don't mean like they they can't
lobby and change laws or you know
protest whatever i mean they're we're
angry about
things that are in the past and we
look for reasons to be angry and we're
looking for reasons to be angry that we
we cannot do a thing about a big example
this played out on a huge stage across
the world
was the decision to start tearing down
statues
and i'm like okay well what's the end
game here
and like you know what's your reason
well they did
x y z and i'm like okay
if we start applying that principle
that you can never be anything or have
any
positive effect or ever get any type of
praise
for anything you did because you have
something bad in your past
then no one is ever going to be
in a position to encourage or inspire
anyone
because people aren't perfect and so
we're at this position where this point
history
where we can't we where you can't
you you can find a way you can finally
get you
you dig hard enough and you can find
a reason to cancel anybody
right and all canceling is all canceling
is an attempt
to change the past you did something
awful
or rather to make you pay for for a
transgression that perhaps
wasn't a transgression but now we've
decided it is
which is even worse you know at least if
you took my money i can say okay i can
see how much you took i'm gonna take
that back and some interest
but if you just decided it was a bad
thing and it wasn't at the time
you know that's that's that's awful we
can't do that and
all it does is just create an endless
cycle of anger because you're always
going to be able to look back and always
move that goal post you're always going
to be able to go okay
i don't feel x y or z is good
so i'm gonna see how many people i can
get to be angry about it and it may be
nothing
here in the u.s i don't know how they
did it over there uh here in the us
a few years ago they decided we could no
longer play
baby is cold outside on the radio right
oh
really wait maybe i had that okay okay
and and i don't remember the reason but
what i know
is that that song's been played for a
long time and
now it's a big deal okay
it's crazy to me right and
and we we decide it's a big deal but
then at the same time we decide newer
things
that if you if you if you weigh them on
the same
block of morality or affect people
you go okay that's crazy someone someone
made it made a great post and i thought
it was hilarious
and then i i share things to stir the
bear or poke the bears and some
and he goes you know how woke do you
have to be
to be offended by baby it's cold outside
but not whop
that that song yes exactly exactly
yeah i'm done and i was like that's good
i'm good
it's good i get it well but but the the
point is
you know until you can let go of things
and we we have a big problem
collectively humanity i think is taking
a backwards step emotionally we we're
not able to
to let go of stuff we want and and you
know you can't let go of it when you
feel like there's something you should
get
for a thing that was passed and
and since you can't extract resources
you're trying to deprive resources when
you can't extract
uh when you can't actually change the
past you're trying to change everyone
feels
in the present towards it they're
actually like physically altering things
right now thinking that that will make a
difference like that changes our history
so i think yeah i think you make an
insane point right
um that it's like how offended how
worked you have to be to be
um offended by a christmas song um
but not offended by yeah what or however
you say like if you think about you know
do you know what i was listening to an
ariana grande song actually um in the
gym the other day
and there's a line right and it and
literally the line is
i won't actually fully say it because i
think like youtube might
do something i don't know but it just f
me until the daylight is the line okay
so it's f me until
until it's daylight right and i'm like
i'm like hold up
i was like when did this happen because
i saw when i was younger
so i i'm 24 but when i was like 10 years
ago when i was 14 or
12 whatever i remember lady gaga had a
song
and the song was let me ride on your
disco stick right
um only like 10 like 10 years later do i
listen back and i'm like oh okay i get
what she's saying oh my god i can't
believe i was singing that next to my
mom in the car
but eff me to the daylight it never used
to be like that
and so how are we encouraging that
how are we encouraging little girls
singing that
right and they will say it they will
swear
but we're like but like oh my god god
forbid
there's a christmas song which is just
you know not
be correct and that's not the only song
i saw on bbc today
let me just get it um so bbc radio 1
will not play original version of fairy
tale of new york um
may be offended by derogatory terms for
gender and sexuality
but we can definitely play by ariana
grande to 10 year old girls effort
until the daylights yeah it's a weird
it's a weird um ploy and
a rare play and here's another thing too
because it's
based on who did it
and not what they did
that creates a huge problem
i'll i mean i'll never forget it was a
great a great post and i'm gonna
paraphrase it
uh because i can't quite remember what i
remember the idea
zooby made a post and he was talking
about he made it he was talking about
uh you know saying the n word and rap
music and you got to understand like
like
can white people say it or not because
um
as there's a black person who's not
american
you gotta understand that that's kind of
confusing to me like
uh is is it a bad word or is it only bad
depends on who says it
oh okay my my thoughts on that you know
i i personally
look okay so so first first and foremost
what people got to understand
uh is that the the n word
used in music is not the same thing that
we were called in the 60s
two different words they're spelled
differently uh
not not like so differently you're going
to confuse them you know but but
they they're they're pronounced
differently they sound differently
they're not the same they're not used
the same
whatever right so so that is the the
first thing i always
make sure i'll bring up is that uh when
you
look at language that's not the same
word there's not the same ideas not
spelled the same it's not used the same
there's nothing about those words that
are same
as far as people getting offended as if
it were the same
mhm that
is
that's problematic that's problematic
because you're deciding that
well and it's and it's not problematic
and because every every group has you
know their own terms you know
that you use within your own people or
are terms that you
you can only like you know i i can call
i i can call my mom and ass
but you know you do it you have a
problem you know that kind of thing
right
the problem but that that's my mom right
now if i made a song
where i'm doing that and all of a sudden
people start coming up and going oh
what's up man
is that your mom that the a-hole in the
song okay now we have a problem
and and so so so now i've got to make a
decision as
is as a gatekeeper of
that's that phrase i gotta go okay is it
cool or is it not cool
and whatever i do has got to be
consistent across the board because
there's going to be a lot of people who
have moms just like mine they're going
to hear
and they're going to go yeah
mom you're like that mom you're in a
hole
too they're like what's wrong with you
like no that's cool
and said it about his mom so i was
saying about
my mom they're totally different
families you know just because you're
both moms
and and the point of my hand this this
was not this this totally ended up being
uh
a better knowledge you know i thought it
was when it came out
but the whole idea the whole point here
is that when you
decide that whether the term is used
amongst
black americans until you go
and realize that there aren't just black
people in america
and those black people don't have the
same history so
it's a hard way to differentiate it
and decide who can say what like when i
was living in portugal man
i was amazed the radio was just playing
this music and it was like
there's no sensors nothing uh which over
here you know
what used to be sensors now i was
listening to the radio of the day and i
was like let's see if they say what they
what they used to censor uh i don't
remember the song but i was
listening intently and they didn't
censor it i was like oh okay it's new
uh i but i guess i guess my point is
uh as much as i wanted to be a person my
personal issue
the people won't let it be because how
can they either they're there
there are enough black people in the
world and enough from
rightfully so that's the other thing
rightfully so
uh can't get offended if it's used i
just think i think if you're gonna if
you're gonna make it a big deal
personally you got to go
you can't use it and you no one can use
it if you use it army won't have a
problem
i've met some older black men who are
just like that they're like don't use
that word around me
i'm like okay that's cool because he's
holding the host holding all of us with
standard
my issue is when you have guys that say
all right it's cool for me
it's not cool for you that's um
that's going to create their own
problems i mean and they're going to be
mad when
when someone shows up you know from from
freaking
would say from from colombia
and they don't they don't know you know
i was in the dominican republic and
and all the people were shouting out to
one another at the resort hey
uh blackie that's what they call one of
them really oh that sounds awful
it's not terrible sounds awful but it's
just the nickname blackie
yeah you couldn't do it back here but
imagine
export out the us knew that you'd have
an issue so so now now i think that
genie's out the bottle
you know it's not going back in
i i but i can't tell people to live with
it
if the rapper is stuck i'll tell you
what here's what happened if the rapper
stopped using in songs i i give it three
years
before for the turn but they're not
gonna stop using it in songs because
it's profitable people want to hear it
so
um yeah i i tend to agree with
everything you said
um i think the biggest okay so i think
there's two parts to it isn't it i think
it's sort of like
taking ownership of a word which meant
one thing and being able to sort of be
like no now this is ours it's you know
taking ownership of that
but i think at the same time i think
this was maybe two years ago i don't
remember
there was there was a black rapper i
can't remember who it was but he
had the n-word in a song and he was
singing live or whatever
and he got a white woman to come up on
stage with him
and um sing the the rap words and it
just so and then so she drops the n-word
but it was in the song
so it caused a lot of issues
yeah everyone shouldn't have said it
well like okay
maybe she shouldn't have done but like
but this it's not clear where do we draw
the line
like is it even possible to have a line
lines are inherently blurry so can we
not just say like no for everyone
and then like move forward and then
people are going to be like hey
and here's what happened if you say no
for everyone thinking like how you gonna
tell me
i can't say it i'm one of
it's a hard one to discuss and
and there is probably never going to be
a right answer
um all you got to do is make sure that
you you're in the
that you don't use it when you're in the
right company uh
a wrong company i guess right it's not
your audience
there you go know your audience because
yeah
i'm with you i'm with you we've come to
an hour which is actually the longest
i've
done a podcast for so that's super cool
so we've oh really
no it's great no no it's fab it's great
i love it i usually go between like
a half an hour to an hour so i usually
end at like 45 minutes
40 maybe 50 minutes but this is great do
you have any
final words do you want you want to say
oh this this has been a
a very fun conversation i had no idea
what was gonna go and i can tell you i
have not talked about about
three of these topics on podcasts ever
no one's ever asked me about uh the
masculinity thing
i thought that was cool uh this whole
war discussion
that that was pretty uh entertaining and
then kind of the direction of of society
uh is very cool this this has been very
fun
and i'm happy that you let me come on
and we could have a chat
in front of your audience yeah
absolutely it's so good to have you so i
want to thank you so much for coming on
i want to um
thank my um sponsors icon plus blog
fight coin flip and i also really want
to thank zelipe because i absolutely
forgot to thank them um and that that's
a big mistake for me so
i'll uh i'll play that sponsorship in a
minute ed thank you so much and guys
don't forget to tune in next week
thursday 12 est bye
[Music]
[Applause]